on
quand l'animation est terminée il faut
mettre les personnages en couleurs avant
on travaillait avec des pinceaux et de
la gouache
maintenant les ordinateurs on remplaçait
la peinture d'abord on a le dessin sur
le papier il est scanné dans
l'ordinateur avec juste très ensuite le
personnage est mis en couleur par
informatique
il faut le remplir en cliquant sur la
bonne couleur la lumière est dessiné
avec du crayon de papier sur des
feuilles le crayonné et d'abord noir
pizzly mis en couleur
l'homme au visage cassez a beaucoup de
couleurs sur son visage cela lui donne
un air bizarre est un peu inquiétant
maintenant on ajoute la lumière dessinée
avec le crayon de papier et pour finir
on ajoute avec l'ordinateur
la pluie et les clairs c'est très long
de crayonnés toutes les lumières sur les
milliers de feuilles mais est une étape
très importante pour garder le style du
dessin grâce à 6 lumière on peut voir le
travail de la main sur toutes les images
du film